keya parrots have more to offer than
just good looks new research suggests
they have the ability to discern
statistical probability in the
experiment they first learned that black
closed bins could be exchanged for food
while orange ones were worthless two
jars were presented to the Kia the first
containing a majority of black bins the
second a majority of orange the Kia
consistently chose from researchers
hands that pick from the first jar even
when the number of pins were the same in
both jars he has selected according to
probability another test examined the
Kia skill at discerning the effect of
barriers in the jars to jars with
barriers were presented containing an
equal total of black and orange pins but
one of the jars had a higher proportion
of black pins above the barrier he
attended to select the hand that picked
from that jar when a one to one ratio of
orange and black pins were present above
the barrier the Kia still selected the
pins taken from the jar with more black
pins on top infants and Apes
demonstrates similar statistics skills
and the results of the study hinted a
common thread between their brains and
those of Kia a fine that could impact
the comparison of brain structures among
animals and possibly inform the study of
artificial intelligence
[Music]
you